surely one couldn't hurt
a greedy Captain Hook is stalking the
streets this Halloween as children have
fun dressing up as Peter Pan and other
characters the u.s. sugar lobby has
their money-grubbing hooks in their
candy basket the American sugar Alliance
lobbies for Stalinist supply control
measures through import and domestic
production quotas that keep us sugar
prices well above world prices for years
the US has paid about double the world
price for raw sugar and leading
researchers have consistently estimated
that the sugar program cost consumers
around 3 billion dollars every year so
sugar beet growers often receive an
extra 30 to 40 thousand dollars a year
in their trick-or-treat baskets but the
average household loses about 25 dollars
a year it would be one thing if sugar
producers were poor but on average farm
households have substantially higher
incomes than the families who bear the
costs of the sugar program hopefully the
ticking clock is getting louder as the
end looms for the u.s. sugar program
should the US continue the sugar program
let us know in our poll also let us know
what other topics you would like our
scholars to cover in 60 seconds and be
sure to LIKE and subscribe for more
research and videos from AEI